after months of theories and debates
about what Marvel Studios was planning
for the next phase of their cinematic
universe
studio head Kevin Feige dropped some
major news at comic-con laying out two
years worth of film and television
projects here's a potentially spoiler
filled look at what we can expect in
Marvel Studios phase four after the
universe shaking events of Avengers
endgame fans were wondering just where
the MCU would go from here so it's no
surprise to learn that the studio is
dedicating phase four to introducing new
characters and ideas and expanding the
idea of what the MCU is and can do 2020
will see the release of Black Widow a
flashback film set between Captain
America's Civil War and Avengers
infinity war as well as eternals which
introduces a whole new mythos to the MCU
2021 will also introduce viewers to a
new hero shang-chi as well as deliver
Marvel's first horror film with the
Doctor Strange sequel and reinvent the
god of thunder yet again in Thor love
and thunder and Marvel will also be
expanding into television with a slate
of new shows and the upcoming Disney
Plus streaming service shows that will
closely tie-in with the film's with all
that going on it's no wonder there
wasn't room for a new Avengers film
making phase 4 the first phase without
an Avengers blockbuster anchoring it's
the next Marvel movie to hit theaters
will be the long-awaited Black Widow
solo film and Feige revealed a ton of
exciting details including the fact that
part of the film takes place in Budapest
maybe we'll finally learn what happened
to Natasha the last time she was there
you will not remember Buddha says very
differently and there was also some
exciting casting news Florence Pugh who
recently dazzled audiences in mid-summer
appeared in the teaser trailer as a
fellow secret agent named Yelena who has
a strained relationship with Natasha it
seems very likely that puce character is
he Elena Bulova who was black widows
successor in the comics given Natasha's
fate in a ventures endgame could this be
a tease of things to come Plus fan
favorite stranger things actor David
Harbor was on hand
revealing that he will be playing Alexi
shikaka
better known as the Red Guardian in the
Soviet Union's counterpart to Captain
America he shares more than just a
homeland with Natasha though in the
comics they were once married Harbor
told Entertainment Weekly in a way he's
a super soldier but he's also a very
complicated guy he has a lot of flaws a
lot of idiosyncrasies it's a very rich
character and the teaser also confirmed
rumors that Black Widow will be battling
the villainous taskmaster just who will
be playing taskmaster is still up in the
air could he actually be Red Guardian in
disguise or someone entirely different
we'll just have to wait and see one of
the biggest surprises of Comic Con was a
shocked announcement that not only is
Natalie Portman returning to the MCU as
Jane Foster
she'll be gaining the powers of Thor as
well directed by Taika Waititi who
helmed the fan favorite thor ragnarok
the fourth movie in the franchise called
Thor love and thunder will be based in
part on a recent run of comics that
featured Jane becoming the new Thor
after the old one was found to be no
longer worthy of wielding Mjolnir you
will not worthy and she's not the only
fan favorite powerhouse returning to the
franchise Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie will
be back and she may have a new lady love
interest after Avengers endgame Feige
announced that Marvel would feature
quote prominent LGBT heroes and Thompson
told the comic-con crowd that Valkyrie
who succeeded Thor as the leader of the
Asgardian people in adventures endgame
would be at the forefront of that push
she explained
first of all as King as new king of
Asgard she needs to find her Queen so
that will be the first order of business
2016 s Doctor Strange was a solid film
but critics dinged it for sticking a
little too closely to the Iron Man story
formula Erik
rich guy falls victim to a surprise
accident and is forced to rebuild his
outlook using new tools etc etc this was
especially surprising considering the
film's director scott derrickson was
best known for horror films like
sinister and The Exorcism of Emily Rose
while that horror background may finally
pay off as derrickson revealed the
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to be the emcee use
first horror film and there's another
unexpected twist elizabeth Olsen Scarlet
Witch will co-star in the film which
will tie into her Disney Plus TV series
Wanda vision it's all coming together
that wasn't the only surprise
announcement regarding Wanda vision
besides Olsen and co-star Paul Bettany
who is reap rising his role as vision
Marvel revealed that dear white people's
Tiana Paris will be appearing in the
show as Monica Rambeau that name should
sound familiar the character who is the
daughter of fighter pilot Maria Rambo
previously appeared as a child in
Captain Marvel and Wanda's fellow
Avenger Hawkeye is also going to be
connecting with the younger generation
on Disney Plus as it was officially
confirmed that the series Hawkeye will
feature Jeremy Renner's Archer Clint
Barton passing on his skills to the new
Hawkeye Kate Bishop in a storyline from
the comics Renner told the crowd I get
to teach someone else how to be a
superhero without superpowers Marvel
also announced details for the upcoming
martial arts flick shang-chi and The
Legend of the ten rings Chinese Canadian
actor C mu Leo will be playing the title
role while Aquafina will be appearing in
an undefined role and Chinese superstar
Tony Lee jung-hee is poised to play
longtime Iron Man villain the Mandarin
who in the comics wields the power of
advanced alien technology shaped in the
ten rings of course a different version
of the Mandarin appeared in Iron Man 3
but it turned out to be an actor named
Trevor Slattery played by Ben Kingsley
Marvel later released a short film
teasing that there is a real Mandarin
out there somewhere and there's a good
chance that Liang's version of the
character will be Shang Chi's father in
the comics shang-chi dedicated his life
to defeating his supervillain father foo
Manchu but since Marvel doesn't own the
rights to that character the Mandarin
could make for a cool if only slightly
less problematic replacements the 10
rings have been teased since the very
beginning of the MCU and the first Iron
Man film so it will be awesome to
finally see that plot thread payoff
who are these people they are your loyal
customers sir they called themselves the
ten rings maybe the biggest jaw-dropper
the whole convention though came during
my geese closing comments first he
teased a bunch of projects beyond phase
four including Fantastic Four in the
x-men Feige said there's a lot of other
stuff we didn't get to talk about today
we didn't even mention that we're making
Black Panther 2 we didn't mention the
fact that guardians of the galaxy 3 is
coming we didn't have time to talk about
Captain Marvel - by the way I didn't
even have time to talk about the
Fantastic Four and there's no time left
to talk about mutants but there was time
to talk about one more thing
blade yes in a true mic drop comment if
Feige welcome two-time Oscar winner
Maher Saleh Ali onto the stage to reveal
that the one-time Copperhead actor from
Luke Cage will be playing blade in a
reboot of the classic Wesley Snipes
action franchise with any luck they'll
make sure to definitely include blades
classic iconic catchphrase
so always trying to ice-skate Oh bill
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite Marvel films are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]